the white house announces that joe biden
will commemorate january 6th as the
congressional commission focuses on mark
meadows text messages the biden white
house blames meat companies for rising
prices and
omicron panic continues i'm ben spearow
this is the ben shapiro show
today's show is sponsored by expressvpn
i protect my data with a vpn so should
you visit expressivevpn.com
ben we will get to all the news
momentarily first if you are looking for
a way to help your budget this holiday
season because let's face it you have a
lot of relatives and you're spending a
lot of money on them we'll spend a
little less money on you and that means
heading over to puretalk because right
now you're spending way too much on your
cell phone bill and you could be getting
yourself or a loved one a new iphone
pure talk has iphone 12s starting at
just 479 bucks through the end of the
year they have 13s as well i switch to
pure talk i'm getting the same great
nationwide 5g coverage as one of the big
companies you can too the average family
saves over 800
a year which is just smart why are you
spending money on your cell phone
provider when you don't have to i would
not tell you to use a service i'm not
happy with i am happy with beer talk usa
and you will be as well make the switch
with puretalk's 30-day risk-free
guarantee you have nothing to lose
unlimited talk text six gigs of data
just 30 bucks a month and as i said the
iphone 12 is going for just 479 bucks
when you switch over head on over to
puretalk.com shop for the plan and phone
that's right for you then enter promo
code shapiro save an additional 50 off
your first month and save on a new phone
that is puretalk.com promo code shapiro
peer talk is simply smarter wireless
some restrictions apply see site for
details alrighty so democrats have
basically decided that since they have
nothing else they're going to run on
january 6 this was perfectly obvious
from nearly the beginning of the year
january 6th has been their talking point
since january 6th now a few notes
january 6 was horrific it was horrific
okay it followed on two months of donald
trump saying things that were not true
about election fraud and that have now
been baked into a certain part of the
republican cake this talk that the
election was stolen from donald trump it
wasn't donald trump lost the suburbs
because donald trump refused to
run anything remotely like a rational
campaign instead he decided that he was
going to tweet him his way out of the
presidency there was no rationale for it
the fact is that donald trump's actual
policy was quite good and maybe he will
return on the strength of those policies
he will not return on the strength of
the tweeting okay so between november
4th and january 6 donald trump said a
lot of things that were overtly untrue
about election 2020. i was not shy about
this at the time then on january 6 a lot
of people who went to a rally in
washington dc that was supposed to be
about the quote-unquote stolen election
some of those people a small percentage
of those people i know the media wants
to make it out like it was everybody
wasn't a small percentage of those
people decided that they were going to
try to break into the capitol building
in an attempt to stop the certification
of the 2020 presidential election and
the police presence was minimal there
were more officers who were protecting
me at berkeley a few years back then
we're protecting you know the capitol
building during the certification of an
election which is kind of crazy they
broke into the building
some people were hurt only one person
was killed ashley babbitt killed by
capitol police and then the building was
cleared and the republicans certified
the election vice president mike pence
donald trump's own vice president
certified the election senator mitch
mcconnell who is the senate majority
leader at the time certified the
election
everything that went down at the capitol
building that day was really bad it
created some horrific imagery
these were active criminality if you're
talking about walking into the capitol
building and doing violence to police
officers obviously and people who commit
acts of criminality no matter the
political side should go to jail
this became the rallying point for
democrats because it was their response
to the fact that they had decided to
allow violence to overtake the country
throughout all of 2020.
it was their response to their own
policy failures
not generous itself their reaction to
january 6th because their reaction to
january 6th was democracy is in true
danger this was a coup attempt it was an
actual insurrection now here's the thing
in order for it to be a coup or an
actual insurrection you require
institutional support there is no
institutional support okay and here's
part of the problem for the democrats
they want to make two simultaneous
arguments argument number one
is that donald trump is solely
responsible for what happened on january
6th and argument number two is that the
entire republican and conservative
infrastructure is responsible for what
happened on january 6th and the truth is
neither of those okay donald trump is
responsible for his bad commentary and
the lies that he told in the run-up to
january 6. he's responsible for that he
is not responsible for people breaking
into the capitol building he literally
said in the middle of his speech that he
wanted people to march over and then
peacefully protest what was happening at
the capitol building and you can say
people then took that too far people
decided they were going to to move into
the arena of violence but i'm very wary
on all political sides of trying to pin
violence on people who don't actively
call for the violence donald trump gets
blamed for heightening the rhetoric he
gets blamed for heightening the
temperature he gets blamed for saying
things that are not true that does not
mean that he's responsible for the
violence that followed at the capitol
building
and again this is my bipartisan opinion
i felt the same way about barack obama
when a when a dallas black lives matter
member movement decided to murder six
police officers
barack obama's rhetoric on the police
had been quite terrible his rhetoric on
race had been quite terrible he was not
responsible for that bernie sanders was
not responsible for the congressional
baseball shooter he said some terrible
terrible things about republicans he
said terrible things about the american
health care system he's not responsible
for a person
misusing those words as a rationale for
trying to murder people and so i'm very
consistent in this particular standard
so it was not all about donald trump
some of the stuff that donald trump said
was bad but this is not the same thing
we have to make these logical
distinctions because otherwise we end up
in a place where essentially everybody
is responsible for everything everybody
else does and there is no
expectation that human beings are going
to act in a rational non-violent way
okay so that's problem with the argument
number one problem number two is that
the democrats have suggested literally
since the day this happened that the
entire republican party the entire
conservative infrastructure stood behind
january 6th and celebrated it and it's
not true
cnn has been saying for a long time that
it was fox news that created january 6th
and cheered january 6 and made excuses
for january 6. well there's one problem
we now have the texts
from members of the fox news codery from
people like laura ingram and sean
hannity allies of the president of the
united states donald trump we have text
from them to mark meadows who's the
chief of staff to donald trump now the
media have taken this as again
proving an argument that they really
have not made the argument that they are
making the big one is that the entire
conservative infrastructure is complicit
in january 6. right that's the big
argument then there's the smaller
argument which is that members of the
media have miscovered january 6th or
downplayed january 6 or attempted to
suggest that january 6 was a false flag
operation that's a separate critique and
i think there is sometimes some accuracy
to that critique frankly i think the
attempt to turn january 6th and some
sort of heroic martyrs play is silly i
think the attempt to turn january s and
and by the way morally counterproductive
i think the attempt to suggest that
january 6th
was all an fbi setup is untrue or that
it was all just antifa riling people up
i don't think that's true the evidence
for that is scanty if if present at all
the evidence on the other side that the
left immediately took january 6 swung
into action in an attempt to censor
everybody that part's true but
that is not to suggest that january 6
was not an activity predominantly and i
believe universally driven by people who
thought they were supporting donald
trump at the time okay but that's a
separate critique from the bigger
critique and the one that they want to
push for 2022. the one they want to push
for 2022 is that january 6th is a
natural outgrowth of republican and
conservative governance that is what
they are attempting to push and the
problem is the case they are currently
making in the january 6th committee is
precisely the opposite which is that
conservatives republicans generally even
the most pro-trump supporters were not
in favor of january 6th and didn't like
it
again you can make the argument that
people are not casting enough stones at
donald trump for his rhetoric and for
his actions during that day and not
immediately deploying the capitol police
or the national guard that's a separate
argument but the big argument that they
need for 2022 is not that because donald
trump paid down the ballot in 2022. the
argument they need is that the entire
republican party and conservative
infrastructure stands behind the actual
activity of january 6 and they can't
prove that case not from the text
messages that have been revealed
yesterday liz cheney announced these
text messages okay so they got a hold of
mark meadows text messages on his cell
phone and those text messages showed a
bunch of members of the republican
congress encouraging trump to step in
and do something and sean hannity and
laura ingram doing the same
which undercuts the entire notion that
the republican party was complicit in
january 6th or that the conservative
commentariat was complicit in the
activity of january 6th again that is
not to alleviate responsibility for
those who promulgated falsehoods about
the stolen election narrative of 2020.
and again you can believe that the
election was not stolen and still have
serious questions about election
security election procedures the
illegality of for example the
pennsylvania supreme court radically
changing election law right you can all
those things can co-exist but that is
not the main line argument the main line
argument of democrats is that
republicans do not deserve to be elected
to public office because they are
inherently dangerous and their rule will
lead to the overthrow of democracy well
what do you make then of the fact that
every major conservative was not only
condemning january 6th in real time but
trying to urge the president to step in
and do something about it at the time
which doesn't suggest complicity in
january 6 does it
indeed according to the records multiple
fox news hosts
knew the president needed to act
immediately
they texted mr meadows
and he has turned over those texts
quote
mark
the president needs to tell people in
the capitol to go home
this is hurting all of us he is
destroying his legacy
laura ingram wrote
please get him on tv
destroying everything you have
accomplished
brian kilmeade texted
quote can he make a statement ask people
to leave the capitol
sean hannity urged
as the violence continued
one of the president's sons
texted mr meadows quote
he's got to condemn this
asap
okay so that is representative liz
cheney who is one of the sole
republicans on this committee
and she voted for trump's impeachment
over over this you know here's the thing
you can tell that the media understand
that
what happened yesterday did not prove
their case that actually undercut their
broad scale case
it has disappeared it was leading the
news as of yesterday morning it is no
longer leading the news at the new york
times instead they've got some generic
piece about republicans embracing
particular bills
okay meanwhile over at the washington
post they're covering omicron and
holding mark meadows in contempt but
they're really not paying too much
attention to exactly what the underlying
narrative is they've lost the threat a
little bit and the reason they've lost
the threat is again because the thread
was not true the thread that the entire
conservative movement was complicit in
january 6th therefore is to be held
blameworthy and therefore 2022 will be a
referendum on that
that that is that is not going to hold
not for 2022 people can see right
through that but this administration is
banking on this narrative they're
banking on the narrative that
republicans are too dangerous to hold
power because they stood by on january
6th or didn't care about january 6th and
january 6th is is the bialendo
this is what there's only one reason why
joe biden plans to commemorate january
6th
and january 6 did far less damage in
terms of of capital in terms of human
life than the widespread riots of
june 2020 and those riots took dozens of
lives those riots resulted in billions
and billions of dollars in damage five
billion dollars in insurable damage far
more in non-insurable damage
and and
if you're talking about cataclysmic
events in american history like the the
actual riots of 2020 i would say have
far more outsized impact on the
political debate than january 6 and
that's not to downplay the evils of
january 6 which i never have done and
never will do but the fact that
democrats are commemorating january 6th
as though it was pearl harbor or
september 11th
it just demonstrates how much they need
the narrative and this is a matter of
political necessity for them at this
point here's jen sackey announcing that
that joe biden plans to commemorate
january 6. if honestly all they can run
on is january 6th which boils down to
essentially three elements lack of law
enforcement at the capitol which we're
still trying to get to the bottom of
donald trump's actions on that day did
donald trump not
not respond to people in the capitol
building and instead let it go on and
donald trump's fibs and untruths leading
up to january 6th if those are the three
things they're relying upon to shift the
election 2022 that's going to be very
difficult for them
because once again
2022 ain't gonna be a bad election 2020.
donald trump's activities on january 6th
are not going to be the election
campaign in 2022
and and the argument
about election fraud is also not going
to be really the main issue of
contention in 2022.
democrats have to hold on to that
because they've got nothing else here
was jen sackey announcing well like what
is that commemoration even gonna look
like joe biden saying you save democracy
nobody believes that nobody believes
truly the democracy was in existential
danger unless you're ian millhiser or
something and you've got your head so
far up your own ass it's coming out your
face again
here is here is jen sackey trying to
push this anyway
i don't have anything to report to you
at this point in time about our plans i
expect we will have more uh as we get
closer to the end of the year
but you know the president of the
president january 6th was uh one of the
darkest days in our democracy uh it was
a day that our our capital our nation's
capital was under attack and i think
there's no question you'll see us
commemorate that day
commemorate that day i mean come on come
on what are you going to commemorate
that the republicans then certified the
election and made joe biden the
presidents of the united states because
that's exactly what happened
and now the reason that they are
misdirecting to january 6 is pretty
obvious they need january 6 because
their governing strategy has been a
complete total epic failure it continues
to be an epic failure we'll get to that
in just one moment first let's talk
about protecting your home this holiday
season check the hall's walls windows
and doors with the best deals of the
year on the award-winning ring alarm i'm
sure we all know about the ring video
doorbell by now but did you know that
ring makes an award-winning alarm ring
alarm is a powerful affordable whole
home security system you can easily
install yourself so whether you're
running across town or across the
country this busy season you and your
loved ones can rest easy knowing that
your home is protected and it's more
than just security ring alarm protects
your home from flood freeze and fire as
well plus it's way cheaper than those
other companies for what they charge for
a month you get an entire year of ring
alarm with professional monitoring right
now for the best deals of the year on
ring alarm go to ring.com forward slash
ben as i'm constantly saying about ring
ring makes me able to to keep an eye on
my kids right i'm away from home i'm at
the office or something and i want to
know what the squishy baby is doing at
any given time i pop up that ring app
and suddenly i can say that my squishy
baby is attempting to eat a bug
in the backyard that that's a thing that
i can do if i so choose this holiday
season deck the halls walls doors and
windows with the best deals of the year
on the award-winning ring alarm go to
ring.com forward slash ben to get a
great deal on a ring alarm security kit
today that is ring.com forward slash ben
go check them out right now
all right so the reason of course that
the the democrats are focusing in on
january 6th is because they suck
not just on a moral level they stink at
actual governing right it is very bad
okay right now the the biden team is in
such a state of disconnect with the
american public it's quite stunning
so yesterday for example joe biden
announced that republicans are in for a
problem in 2022 of course he announced
this
in his own inimitable way he cannot
speak english anymore he uh i will admit
that it is incredible you know america
is a nation of first we have the first
black female vice president we've had
the first black president already and
now we have the first president to whom
english is a second language here's joe
biden
now we look at 2022
i want to tell my republican friends get
ready bal you're going in for a problem
and we need to stay unified i'm going to
say go get ready but we need to stay
unified you're ready
bow who's bell you're ready bell
you're going in for a bamboozled amtrak
joey
and two gay men kiss on a street corner
in wilmington delaware in 1872.
that's the best of america joey amtrak
mcfoodlehead
so so this
human
uh who is losing capacity rapidly like
it's it's weird to watch someone lose
have you ever seen somebody slip
into unconsciousness as they're being
anesthetized it's like watching the
president except it's a little bit
slower with joe biden
usually you know they if they do it to
you it's like count back from 10 you're
like 10
orange
and that's that's joe biden except we're
watching it
happen over the course of like a few
years here
getting then getting like joey and and
then we're gonna we'll get ready
balangadu
so um meanwhile the good news is that if
you if you love joe biden you might love
even more nancy pelosi uh you know a
country is on the downhill slide when
all of its leaders are dead
and
all of our leaders are not with us any
longer nancy pelosi is 800 years old joe
biden
is now challenging methuselah for oldest
living human
uh here is here's nancy pelosi though
announcing that joe biden is perfect
well it makes sense she thinks he's
perfect because she might be clinically
blind at this point here we go
our country could not be more
could not be better served than with his
most experienced capable hands than
yours president biden he's just perfect
the timing couldn't be better madam vice
president were inspired by your work for
the people as you continue to be an
invaluable partner to president biden
you're such a valuable partner we've
deployed you
to the border
of saskatchewan
and also joe biden is he's a he's the
perfect man
because what i consider to be the
is an actual embalmed
man
who's been dead for a while but is well
preserved
yeah guys things are going great
meanwhile the inflation measures uh
wholesale prices rose 9.6
in november from one year ago that is
the fastest pace on record
according to the producer price index
for final demand it increased 9.6
percent over the previous 12 months
after rising another 0.8 in november
economists have been looking for an
annual gain of 9.2 percent according to
factset you know when economists keep
being shocked
maybe they're not great at their job
maybe at a certain point they should
start you know overestimating just go
over just be like okay you know what i
think it's 9.2 percent i'm going to
ballpark this thing and say it's 9.6
just because i'm always wrong excluding
food energy and trade services prices
rose 0.7 percent for the month
putting core ppi at 6.9 also the largest
gain on record
this is exciting stuff
the labor department's record-keeping
for the headline number goes back to
november 2010.
those numbers come with headline
consumer prices running at their fastest
pace in nearly 40 years core inflation
is at the hottest in about 30 years
well the good news is that our geniuses
by by the way the the prices of like
actual commodities at the store are
insane
according to the daily wire ben zeiss
loft reporting
here are the uh largest consumer spikes
between november 2020 and november 2021
gas is up 58 used vehicles are up 31
hotels are up 26
meat poultry and fish 13
furniture and bedding 12
new vehicles 11 domestic services 10
jewelry 7 electricity 6.5
food 6 percent apparel 5 milk four point
six percent fruit and vegetables four
percent
forty five percent of americans
according to gallup report that recent
price increases are causing their family
some degree of financial hardship ten
percent say that it is a severe hardship
affecting their standard of living
another 35 say the hardship is moderate
71 of those living in households making
less than 40 grand a year say recent
price hikes have caused their family
financial hardship of course because
inflation always hits those with lowest
income the hardest
those are the people who require every
dollar when your dollar doesn't go as
far then um yeah it's going to hurt you
the most
meanwhile the senate just continues to
blow out the spending
so congress has now approved a measure
that would raise the debt ceiling by 2.5
trillion dollars that's house democrats
on wednesday
according to the washington post the
early morning vote in the house came
less than a week after a lawmaker struck
an unusual bipartisan deal that allowed
democrats to adopt the increase in
republicans to oppose it without putting
the country at risk of missing a
critical december 15th deadline the
senate adopted that proposal on tuesday
the bill now goes to president biden for
his signature and joe biden is
celebrating this he's very very happy
that we have increased the debt ceiling
he says this is about being responsible
because again the president of the
united states is not a sane person any
longer this bill will reassure all the
economic markets at home and around the
world that we're going to continue to
pay our debts when they are due
and that's what this is all about i
swear to god the guy slurs it like
somebody has pumped morphine and threw
an iv into him it's crazy it's crazy
okay
we're paying our bills and that's what
this is all about we're responsible some
manga dudes we're problems with citizens
like uh like our citizens and streamers
that excuse me who is you
quick note on us responsibly paying our
bills so the other day had a big credit
card bill i'm a responsible person and
so what i did is i immediately took out
a second credit card to pay for my first
credit card just like a responsible
person
would do i love how the notion of
government responsibility is uh i
already took out this giant giant loan
and now i'm going to take out a second
mortgage on my home i'll take out like a
reverse mortgage to pay for my original
mortgage or something like what are you
talking about what are you this is
responsible spending according to the
president of the united states and they
continue to push build back better which
is going to cost five trillion dollars
cnbc by the way says there's no sign
that the price increases are abating
here's cnbc yesterday
it's not just the final demand it's that
you still have inflationary pressures in
the pipeline here uh intermediate goods
unprocessed goods so there's no sign
that the pipeline of price increases is
easing
okay so um yes that is obviously true
the good news is this administration has
a ready explanation for why prices are
raging out of control and no it's not
their own crappy monetary policy no it's
not their own bad coveted regulations no
it's not their lockdown ideas or the
supply chain shortages that they have
helped filament it's none of those
things it turns out it's greed
oh you see when the prices go up it's
greed so when your meat costs more at
the market it's because the people who
slaughter the cows suddenly got greedy
like a year ago they weren't greedy they
were real altruistic then when the
prices were super low
prices are just a reflection of grade
okay this particular view of economics
is so benighted and bewilderingly stupid
as to boggle the mind
prices are not a reflection of people's
greed greed is a constant in human
nature
in fact self-interest is a confident is
a constant in human nature and
self-interest can only be served by
providing a product at a price people
are willing to pay if it were just about
greed then meat producers could be
charging one million dollars a pound
because after all they're greedy for
lots of money right
but if the idea is that meat producers
are randomly raising their prices out of
greed not reflecting underlying market
conditions like labor shortages and
supply chain bottlenecks and the
inflationary economy created by this
administration
you're out of your mind
and greed alone cannot explain price
increases because again it is a constant
in human nature
but here's gensake trying to again the
real reason meat prices are going up is
because of this administration's garbage
policies but here's jen saki saying that
it's really because of greed it's greed
it's greed
the president the secretary of
agriculture have both spoken to what
we've seen as the greed of meat
conglomerates that is an area when
people go to the grocery store and
they're trying to buy a pound of meat
two pounds of meat 10 pounds of meat
it is the prices are higher that is in
his view and the view of our secretary
of agriculture because of you could call
it corporate greed short you could call
it uh jacking up prices uh uh during a
pandemic it was greed it's price gouging
okay now even price gouging the way the
government usually defines it is not
price gouging usually price gouging
means that a gas station is running out
of gas and so they have to price the gas
so as to ensure that people still get
gas okay when you keep the price low it
artificially stimulates demand that is
what happens with price and supply
curves
okay but but again
the the democrats always have a ready
explanation for why things are going bad
and it's because people are agreed they
did this with obamacare too right you'd
see companies that would increase their
prices to compensate for the fact that
they now had to pay for obamacare and
then they would put that on their bills
and you remember the obama
administration the media being like how
dare they that just demonstrates how
greedy they are no it demonstrates that
when you artificially boost the prices
of things people have to boost the
prices that they charge to the downline
consumer
there's a weird pattern i've noticed
that crops up when it comes to the
understanding of price in the democratic
mindset
that that weird coincidence is that
every major industry that is private is
bad but every policy democrats push is
somehow altruistic and good
so for example it's not just meat
consumers i mean it's not just meat
producers it is also the oil companies
remember when oil spiked shen sake this
is just a couple of weeks ago gensake
suggested that the reason that the oil
prices were spiking was not because of
their crappy policy it was because of um
the oil executives and their greed too
it's always greed when it's when it's
people that the administration doesn't
like
the price at the pump usually moves
alongside the price of refined gas but
recently as you noted there's been a
split where the price of refined gas is
going uh down but prices at the pump are
going up that's exactly why the
president sent the letter to the ftc
last week because that's not what we
should see as the trend there shouldn't
be price gouging across the country you
shouldn't have oil ceos bragging out
there about the profits that they
benefit from when when prices are high
at the gas pump okay so it's all about
the greed of the oil executives however
when it comes to labor and the price of
labor right which is a commodity labor
is a commodity and the wages are going
up which means that you're going to
drive prices up as well when the price
of labor goes up that is not because of
the greed of people who are attempting
to get back in the labor market of
course then it's still the greed of
employers it's still the people who hire
it's because those stupid employers are
so greedy that they won't hire people at
p at wages that people don't want to
don't actually want to take and so the
wages are going up
so
in other words the people who create who
demand a particular price for their
goods and services are bad except if
they're good here's jin saki explaining
we know we've seen labor shortages in
some industries in some industries
that's because they need to have a more
competitive package to offer to workers
it's a workers market right now we know
that people are looking for more
dependable benefits they're looking for
uh wages that are higher and that's
something that is incumbent on a lot of
industries to meet the moment on okay
the reason this administration is
failing on economics is because they
have a perspective that is not in
consonance with reality
it's heads i win tails you lose if the
price of oil is too high it's because
the producers are really bad if the
price of labor is too high it's because
the laborers are really good and the
employers are really bad no matter what
the producers are really bad always the
companies and corporations are really
bad and the government's really good
they're really wonderful and if we have
to blow out the national debt in order
to promote this idiotic idea well
nobody's really worried about the
national debt here is jen saki saying
that the national debt is just a lie no
one actually cares about the national
debt here's the thing about the national
debt no one cares about the national
debt until it bites them directly in the
ass the national debt is all fun and
games until it turns out that servicing
the national debt is eating up a
substantial chunk of your budget every
single year and you have to use
austerity measures like they've had to
use in europe in order to get your
budget back into realignment because
there ain't no one left to pay the bills
and no one's buying the bonds anymore
because there's no promise they will get
paid back but here's gensake pretending
the national debt doesn't matter because
of course she's a devotee as this entire
administration of the idiotic modern
monetary theory which suggests you can
just pump money into the economy at
record rates and nothing will happen
what do you say to people who say we're
just going to be having the same
conversation a little bit over a year
from now
i'm not sure what american person is
saying that or is concerned about the
debt limit but maybe there's somebody
you've met on the street i don't know
but i will say that
you know our view the president's view
is that this has been done in a
bipartisan way the american people
shouldn't be worried about whether or
not elected officials are doing what
they should do and raising the debt
limit to make sure we're covering bills
that have already been incurred no
nobody's nobody's worried about the debt
limit nobody's worried about the
national debt uh okay so they're not
worried about inflation and if they are
it's because they're dumb
and they're not worried about the
national debt and if they are it's
because they're numb
in fact it turns out that everybody
who's unhappy with this administration
is just wrong
how convenient if you're a democrat and
then when you point this out to them and
well well january 6th well well well
january 6 meanwhile by the way in in all
the major cities that are governed by by
blue
government members
the economy is stagnating
new york city job growth is completely
falling apart matthew hogg and patrick
mcgeehan reporting for the new york
times since the start of the year nearly
6 million jobs have been added in the
united states the unemployment rate has
plummeted to 4.2 percent close to where
it stood before the pandemic but in new
york city the economy appears to be in a
rut after getting 350 000 jobs in the
last months of 2020 employment has
slowed considerably this year with just
187 000 jobs added since march the
city's unemployment rate is 9.4
9.4 that's more than double the national
average its decline in recent months was
largely caused by people dropping out of
the labor force as the city plunged into
its worst financial crisis since the
great depression the unemployment rate
skyrocketed in june 2020 it was 20
percent now it's down to about 10
percent but new york has added back a
little more than half the jobs it lost
according to the state labor department
far less than the rest of the country
the protracted pandemic has shut out
tourists scared off the crush of
suburbanites who filled office towers
every weekday
just eight percent of office workers
were back at work five days a week in
early november
okay so they're wrecking their own
economy
and then the idea is that what you're
supposed to ignore that because donald
trump's a bad man who does bad things
who's bad
same thing is happening in illinois by
the way according to the wall street
journal
illinois is losing young people while
florida is gaining them there's a shock
state development specialist zack
kennedy notes the us population actually
grew in the prime working age young
adult age cohorts 25 to 29 30 to 34 35
to 39 illinois was among the few states
to see a decline in those age cohorts
one reason is many students who leave
the state for college don't come back
only new jersey lost more college-aged
individuals out of states who never
returned
one of the reasons for that is because
illinois has
huge taxes
illinois new jersey have some of the
highest residential property tax rates
in the nation
the state is losing children its under
18 population has declined by 350 000
over the last decade
lousy schools are driving away young
families
each illinois household is on average on
the hook for a hundred and ten thousand
dollars in government worker retirement
debt
a hundred and ten thousand dollars for
each illinois household in terms of
state debt burden
this is what happens when you're in a
state like garbage
so there's been the good news is that
again it's all misdirection you notice
that it's almost direction right when
they fail it's about january 6th or or
in california it's about making a
californian abortion sanctuary state to
deflect attention from the fact that the
governance there is absolutely terrible
or that they're doing a full-on mask
mandate indoors again in california
based on
mcran in new york they're attempting to
misdirect by suggesting that they go
after lawmakers i mean after after gun
makers new york attorney general leticia
james she said she was on the view
explaining that that new york state was
going to lead the nation and going after
gun makers yeah that's going to fix your
economy let's show it sounds great
gun manufacturers and gun distributors
in this country are immunized no
liability whatsoever they're the only
industry that is protected in this
country and given the carnage and given
the fact that this is the ninth
anniversary of sandy hook i am sick and
tired of prayers and individuals whose
hearts go out to all of those who have
lost lives we can do something about it
and what we need to do is hold these gun
manufacturers and these gun distributors
[Applause]
okay but all of that is just a
distraction and you can woo that up as
much as you want view audience when
democrats are losing because they are
disconnected from the everyday reality
of most americans nowhere is that truer
than with regard to covet where they
continue to promulgate the law that they
can shut down coven when they can't
come close to doing so we'll get to that
in just one moment the delusions are
insane first let's talk about the
perfect gift for the dude in your life
before christmas i am talking of course
about steak omaha steak yes this is what
every man is waiting for on christmas go
to omahasteaks.com enter code shapiro in
the search bar save over 50 when you
order the perfect gift package today for
99.99 you'll get the world famous bacon
wrapped filet mignons chicken breasts
sides desserts and so much more when you
use code shapiro it'll not only save
over 50 you'll get an additional eight
omaha steaks burgers free with your
order omaha steaks is ready to ship now
order the perfect gift package today at
omahasteaks.com don't forget you'll get
eight free burgers when you enter code
shapiro in the search bar and if you're
a new customer ordering for the first
time enter shapiro at checkout to get 20
bucks off select packages achieve
gifting greatness with omaha steaks
incredible flavor incredible value 100
guaranteed omahasteaks.com
keyword shapiro i'm telling you that
deal that they have on that perfect gift
package is just spectacular i'm here
talking about four bacon wrapped
flamingos four boneless chicken breasts
four almost eggs burgers four gourmet
jumbo franks four individual scallop
potatoes four caramel apple tarts a jar
of signature seasoning and free eight
omaha steaks burger and that's that's a
hell of a deal head on over to
omahasteaks.com keyword shapiro and make
the dude in your life happy for
christmas alrighty we'll get to the
insane coveted policies that continue to
shut down the nation in just one moment
first
speaking of those uh you may have
noticed that we here at the daily wire
have been fighting the vax mandates
literally from day one and we have been
asking you to help us out by heading on
over to do not comply petition do not
comply petition.com the reason is we
need as many signatures on that thing as
possible we need we need everybody to
sound off on the fact that they are not
going to comply with the vax mandates
pushed by this administration and pushed
locally as well i mean now new york city
is trying to expand the vax mandate to
kids age 5 to 11. this is all insane we
have a goal of reaching a million
signatures we already have 875 000
signatures we need your help to cross
the finish line before your end so
please sign the petition at
dailywire.com do not comply share our
petition with all of your friends and
family but send a message so loud the
biden administration cannot ignore us
you're listening to the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast and radio
show in the nation
[Music]
so again democrats have to rely on
something in order to get them out of
the state that they are in but they
cannot rely on their own policy because
their policies are garbage and this is
particularly true with klovit they've
lost the threat they've completely lost
some of them know this by the way
there's an entire article in politico
today about how democratic governors are
starting to realize that they've gone
too far
according to politico the party's defeat
last month in virginia has many
democrats searching for an off-ramp to
the pandemic that allows them to sell a
brighter future to voters next november
asked in an interview about his november
close call for example new jersey
governor phil murphy who almost lost to
a person who no one knows i mean he may
have lost to an actual not human being
like to a ghost or something he
attributed it to quote a lot of folks
who are frustrated is my guess
murphy said some new jerseyans feel like
government is not connecting with them
they're sick of masks being told what to
do in terms of vaccines probably not
thrilled with what they sense is going
on in washington they may have lost a
job or a business that went bust or a
loved one worse yet
yeah that yes that's that's correct
north carolina roy cooper governor roy
cooper said i think we have to recognize
and acknowledge that families have had a
tough time over the past two years both
health-wise whether it is or isn't from
copen whether it's mental health and
economically
so democrats are starting to realize
that they have gone way too far on the
stuff but here's the problem they can't
back out of it there's no way for them
to back out of it they made a promise
and the promise was a lie the promises
they could shut down the virus joe biden
literally promised this on twitter he
said he was going to shut down the virus
that was not ever within the capacity of
the government the government could take
a particular concrete action they could
incentivize the creation of vaccines and
they could help distribute them that was
all the things they could do they could
not shut down the virus because the
government is not god see here's the
thing you know as a religious person
you look back at religious history and
you read original biblical text and what
it sounds a lot like is that people in
early religious life thought that god
was kind of a gumball machine right that
if you did what god wanted the reigns
would come that if you did what god
wanted then your crops would grow if you
did what god wanted then your wife
wouldn't die in childbirth and then they
quickly looked around and they realized
pretty quickly that that isn't true you
could do many of the things you think
god wants and bad things will still
happen to you right this is what the
entire book of job is about you can do
all the things god wants and bad stuff
can still happen to you and so religious
people change their view of god that's
what the book of job is about religious
people realize that there is in fact
things that there are things in the
universe that you cannot control because
when you say that if you do x god will
respond with why what you're really
saying is that the entire universe is
within your control not god's control so
religious people rethought how they
interacted with god and how they
interacted with nature and they realized
you could do all the good things but
there had to be some inherent value to
doing the good things beyond the
consequences you thought that you would
receive on this earth from the divine
okay now
take that to government the innate human
instinct to control all that is around
us means that that religious instinct if
you're not a religious person and
particularly not a sophisticated
religious person can be channeled in
other directions and so when you have
people who act like pagan prophets of
old suggesting that if you do x the
government will provide you with why if
you just wear the mask if you just lock
down long enough if you keep your kids
out of public parks and schools if you
do those things then the government will
save you from covet and it turns out
government cannot do that instead of you
doing the same thing religious people
did thousands of years ago and realizing
that the promise was a lie and perhaps
you should rethink your relationship
with the government and what government
is capable of doing
instead of doing that people have
doubled down they've decided that no the
real answer is that you were not devout
enough if you discouraged yourself if
you whipped yourself if you made
yourself more subservient to government
if you gave up your independence of the
heart then perhaps government would
finally bestow upon you all the things
that you deserve for having done what
government told you to do the most
religious people in american life right
now are people on the far left and
apparently the moderate left who believe
that if they perform acts of obeisance
to the government the government will
provide them with everything they could
possibly need
and members of the government are more
than happy to continue pushing that
notion because it means they get to
maximize their power it means they get
to keep telling you the lie
but here's the thing they know it is a
lie they know it is a lie right rashel
walensky head of the cdc she said
yesterday we probably won't shut down
the virus there's no probably you're not
shutting down the virus but that is not
stopping her from promoting policies
that are designed at zero covet that are
aimed at zero covet rochelle lenski
literally said the day before so
yesterday she says we can't shut down
the virus the day before she's talking
about the new pfizer drug which you've
taken within the first three days
reduces hospitalization and death by 90
percent have taken within the first five
by 88 percent she was talking about that
drug and she said yes but it's better if
you never get it at all covet yes but
you can't control that so they want it
both ways in their more candid moments
they will admit that they have been
lying to you for two years about their
capacity and what they can do
and then they buy it back so here she
was admitting that the reality which is
the government does not have the power
to do the things that governments all
over the world have been promising their
citizens they would do here she was on
cbs mornings
we're not really going to get an all
clear are we we just have to face the
fact that we're going to have to live
with this true i think that that's
probably too true but what i would say
is we have a lot of control and power to
do that as we come together as we get
vaccinated as we do those prevention
things that work to protect one another
and ourselves and our family we can
bring down the amount of disease in this
country and get much faster to that
place okay i don't know what she's
talking about in terms of quote unquote
bringing down the amount of disease in
the country one of the things we know
about oh macron is that a lot of people
who are vaccinated are getting infected
in fact according to axios everything
points to a large wave a large wave is
coming a senior biden official told
axios it will be fast it won't be as
severe but there will be plenty of
hospitalizations
actually
omicron is far less severe than delta
according to the south african analysis
by discovery health the risk of hospital
admission among adults diagnosed with
omicron is 29
lower than it was during south africa's
first wave of infections in 2020.
the researchers adjusted their
calculations by vac status
during the current omicron wave by the
way the two-dose regimen of vaccine was
still 70 effective against severe
disease requiring hospitalization
it found that two doses of pfizer are 33
effective against infection but who
cares about the levels of infection you
care mostly about severe disease right
okay so here's the bottom line we should
all be back to normal
we should get vaccinated get back to
normal or don't get vaccinated live your
life and then pay the consequences
right these are
this is the reality and by the way
omicron is not killing people okay
omicron on a broad level has killed as
far as we know so far on planet earth on
the entire planet filled with trillions
with billions and billions of human
beings
on this entire planet
the grand total number of people who
have died of omicron documentedly
won
one okay that is that is according to
the uk one person has now died of
omicron
okay which means once again ted kennedy
has killed as many people as omicron
okay that that is and yet everybody's
shutting down because they have to
maintain the religious illusion that if
you do what they say they can fix all of
your problems and so for example and
they're lying to you by the way the
white house canceled a lavish christmas
party because of omicron
according to the uk daily mail joe biden
and first lady jill biden will host
holiday open houses instead of cocktail
parties for the holiday season so
visitors can see the decorations in the
white house in a coved friendly way
joel biden's spokesman michael larosa
said anyone who knows the bidens knows
how much they enjoy hosting and
celebrating the holidays in the coming
days we'll host a limited number of
holiday open houses inviting guests to
see the christmas decorations in person
it is disappointing we cannot host as
many people as the bidens would like to
but as we have done since day one of the
biden administration we will continue to
implement strong coveted protocols
developed in consultation with our
public health advisors by the way joe
biden went to a big holiday party
yesterday literally yesterday
uh so yeah it it it only applies to you
meanwhile in cornell cornell is even
more insane so over at cornell cornell
does have a vax mandate in order to
attend campus you have to be vaccinated
they are shutting down the entire campus
and declaring code red
okay
this is crazy they're declaring code red
over a virus that is not killing young
people on a campus that is entirely
vaccinated
because the religious illusion must be
maintained if only if only you performed
animal sacrifices then perhaps covet
would leave you alone
by the way a lot of this is tied to how
the media began to cover covet last year
which was that it was some sort of
global scourge as a response to trump
right it was trump's fault trump created
it trump was it was the trump virus
according to people on the left and so
now they can't disconnect from that
narrative because the narrative last
year was it was trump's fault if anybody
died from covid
well they can't allow that it's biden's
fault if anybody died from covets that
means that covet is actually a moral
virus it only strikes you if you are
evil if you're a black lives matter
protester spitting on other people
twerking in the streets for george floyd
you're fine
if however you're a person who bucks the
conventional wisdom and you decide to
take your kid to a public park and then
you get covered it's because you're bad
even if you're entirely vaccinated if
you oppose vax mandates and you get
covered it's because kovid was punishing
you kovit is a is a pagan god at this
point
according to the ithaca voice the
tompkins county health department
reported four more deaths reported on
monday december 13th bringing the local
death toll from coven 19 to 45 people
but the four deaths were all of older
adults none of them were from cornell
three of us occurred in local nursing
homes but doesn't matter cornell has now
closed many of its campus buildings to
students after finding evidence of oh
macron
faculty and staff are still allowed to
enter offices and work locations but the
school moved its alert level to red
signaling a high risk of spread among
the school community they've completely
lost the threat the nfl by the way is
now mandating boosters for coaches and
staff after a record number of players
tested positive for covet
okay those boosters again we're talking
about for 25 year old
really really in shape dudes that's what
we're talking about right now and the
data show that the original two dose
is is good enough to protect you against
hospitalization and death but now the
nfl is mandating boosters
yeah but the good news is that the head
of the nih who is all about the science
uh he sings songs about us this is
[Music]
past exciting pandemic
masks will
come off
no
more
need for a nose swab
every time
we cough
that's the head of your nih gang
all science
all the time
all the time got religious rituals
we have
hymns now
we have saints like dr anthony fauci he
sainted and glorious vote of candle dr
anthony fauci
if you worship hard enough then the
skies will open and the rain will fall
if you draw a circle around yourself
like honey the circle maker in the
talmud and you just stand there praying
to the gods of cope coveted will be
alleviated but if you step outside that
circle covet will smack you so hard
it'll make your head spin
if this sort of mentality is not going
to lead to any sort of recovery in the
united states is just going to lead to
continued downturns and that's what
you've seen in blue areas
and when you cut yourself off at the
knees because you are disconnected from
reality economically in terms of
pandemics in terms of anything
reality is going to hit you reality will
clock you across the face and so the
only excuse you are left with is just
yelling about how bad your opponents are
and that's what democrats have been left
with which is why joe biden is going to
be doing some sort of commemoration of
january 6th when in reality i thought we
elected him to you know be the president
of the united states not to be the guy
who just spends all day
eating oatmeal watching matlock and then
talking about a thing that happened a
year ago
in part caused by a president
who is no longer in office alrighty
we'll be back here later today with an
additional hour of content in the
meantime go check out dailywire.com do
not comply please sign our petition
against the vax mandates we are
approaching 1 million signatures we need
your help we'll be back here later today
with an additional hour of content
coming up soon is the matt wall show
airing at 1 30 pm eastern be sure to
check it out over at dailywire.com i'm
ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feld executive producer jeremy
boring our supervising producer is
mathis glover production manager pablo
wydowski associate producer bradford
carrington host producer justin barber
the show is edited by adam sciovitz
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by fabiola christina
production assistant jessica kranz the
ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021
on the matt wall show we talk about the
things that matter real issues that
affect you your family our country not
just politics but culture faith current
events all the fundamentals if they
matter to you come check out the show